[Applause]
all right
[Music]
[Applause]
that's right
oh yeah
happy happy Tuesday everybody I hope you
miss me because I missed you
was a long four day weekend and I mean
long anyway so if there's anybody who
knows anything about raising children
well you know it's Joe Biden
look at that huh
[Applause]
now there's someone who needs a puberty
blocker in his 50s
now what you're about to see is the
president talking about kids on a
program called The Daily Show not sure
if you heard of it it's kind of a lot
like this show which we also do every
day except the differences we have
viewers
the topic oh you're gonna love it
transgender kids
uh transgender kids is a really harder
day thing what's going on in Florida
is as my mother would say close to
sinful I mean it's just terrible what
they're doing
what what what are they thinking about
here
they're human beings they love they have
feelings they have inclinations that are
I mean it just to me is
I don't know it's cruel
why does he always sound like he's
mixing Nyquil with Xanax
not that I would know
either that or you rolled off a bassinet
as a child but anyway if there's any
president in history that belongs on the
comedy channel it's this one talk about
a transition he went from English to
gibberish in mere seconds
the moment after he was elected Biden is
referring of course to Florida's new
bill that would block gender affirming
care for transgender minors
that means no puberty blockers crosses
cross-sex hormones or surgical
procedures for anyone under 18. yeah
that's terrible right
so it's close to sinful what's happening
in Florida because in the dim recesses
of Biden's mind it's sinful to not
irreversibly mutilate a confused child
well unless they're in the womb of
course
he actually wants to make it illegal to
stand in the way of a surgeon castrating
a little boy because he's been convinced
he's actually a little girl by Green
haired teachers with more piercings than
a bait and tackle shop
no
but if a guy
sorry I just spit
but if a guy in an old van went around
your neighborhood chopping up little
kids you'd want him thrown in jail but
now Biden appears to want to throw them
a parade in Joe's mind kids who are too
young to cross the road alone can
somehow consent to surgery
but I guess for Joe it's more girls hair
to sniff
he's right about one thing though those
children are human beings and that's why
so many Americans are so horrified about
what's being done to them how is this a
winning message for the Democrats in
2024 it's not even a winning message for
the Vikings in 700 A.D
it's primitive and delusional like when
a monkey tries accounting
one yeah okay and Biden
Biden is not done even if we let them
turn Billy into Millie the poor kid is
still doomed after all Mother Nature let
her wrath be seen over the last two
years
Mother Nature let her wrath be stand for
the last two years floods droughts all
the things and so people can't deny it
anymore if we don't keep the temperature
from going above 1.5 degrees Celsius
raised now we're in real trouble that
whole generation is damned I mean it's
not hyperbole not hyperbole
the whole generation is damned that's
exactly the definition of hyperbole the
old coot so adorable when he's not in
power he's adorable when he's in power
scary as hell
and what a message of Hope right I
haven't seen an old man this pissed
about temperature since Bernie Sanders
got the heating bill for second and
third homes
fortunately Biden has a solution to our
energy needs I bet he was up in
Massachusetts
for example I was up in
Massachusetts on the largest coal
producing electric facilities in the
nation well guess what we hooked it up
to wind technology yeah windmills nobody
knows more about producing wind than Joe
just ask his day nurse
yeah let's just roll Biden's wheelchair
in front of some windmills then drop a
pound of lentils in a smoothie and let
them rip
yeah
you might be wondering how Biden keeps
his mind so razor sharp when there's so
little of it left I bet his focus is
just stay focused
my focus is just stay focused
that came from the federal department of
redundancy departments
otherwise known as Kamala
but he needs that Keen mental focus
because look in this period he inherited
I think it's fair to say a gigantic mess
economically and politically
in this period i inherited I I think
it's fair to say a gigantic Mass
economically and politically I don't
know what he said there that's not
counting the one he made on the rug this
morning
yeah he inherited these problems just
like he inherited that Airline too
he also repeated his huge lie about
creating 12 million jobs when really he
created just to to guard Hunter's
International book of who like
crack
um
should I said hookers yeah you would
have been okay with hookers then there's
on gay marriage I bet he can remember
exactly where his Epiphany was
I can remember exactly where my Epiphany
was I was a senior in high school and my
dad was dropping me off I remember about
to get out of the car and I looked to my
right and two well-dressed men in suits
kissed each other and I never forget I
turn to look to my dad he said Joey it's
simple they love each other
and those two men were Corn Pop and Babe
Ruth
[Applause]
two men in well-dressed suits this never
happened we can safely say that never
happened that was like he saw that in a
commercial last week for a bank
of course he left out the part where he
opposed gay marriage for 50 years of his
career a decade after that Epiphany he
said gays in the military and government
pose security risks to the country and
in the 90s he voted for the Defense of
Marriage Act I guess maybe he was just
anti-gay for pay
of course
somebody got that
these well-dressed men over here
of course The Daily Show was able to
score this fascinating interview because
Cal Penn worked in the Obama admin
Administration as and I need to take a
deep breath here the associate director
of The White House Office of Public
engagement and intergovernmental affairs
which is a fancy way of saying who the
hell is this again
kudos to Comedy Central for finding a
host with less Charisma than Chelsea
Handler I guess Al Gore was unavailable
but it makes sense Biden was on The
Daily Show a daughtering old fool who
can't get the job done on a show that no
one watches anything to add Joe
no no no look look come on is I said it
before I'll say it again look this stuff
never changes all right
what's in the good book what's the first
words of the Bible in the bedagoning in
the nabing
in the benign
benign
in the beginning
shut the hell with it yes let's
woke up tonight's guess his comedy shows
are like daylight savings you'll feel
like you just lost an hour writer
comedian Joe Mackey
yeah
there's a word for women like her and
that word is armed former governor of
Alaska Sarah Palin
[Applause]
he's my spiritual twin only younger
taller and better looking host of
Lawrence Jones cross country on Saturday
night's Lawrence Jones
she's fiery wiry and keeps a knife in
her diary Fox News contributor cat Tim
[Applause]
so Joe I'm looking at you I'm reminded
that yes tax season is upon us
and it's good to see that you've taken
on some additional work at H R Block
after the after we do the taping Greg
I've got to up my game here I've got
Lawrence on the show I've got a former
vice presidential candidate I want to
look good yeah yeah all right
having these surgical advancements when
you were a teen and Confused tomboy
named Regina
there's some problems with your
with you I was extremely tough and cool
Young
budding man in my teens and I have grown
into the Adonis that you see for you
tonight
but I'll tell you what Greg I don't know
if I could listen to to Biden you know
kind of tell us about a story about uh
being a high school senior in this story
about a gay couple kissing because I
don't believe that he remembers being a
senior in high school you know I don't
want to hear about climate change from a
guy who owns a beach house I don't want
to hear about creating 12 million Jobs
when he leaves out the part that he
supported the lockdowns that eliminated
those 12 million jobs the only jobs he's
created are 87 000 for the IRS yeah he
always seems to leave out the
exculpatory evidence he's all for
Criminal Justice Reform to get rid of
the crime bill that he sponsored
to say for me I'm going to start making
eye contact with people
baby steps Joe baby steps
you don't want to creep people out too
late for that
you know uh Governor I there are two
elements to this one is it's the
hypocrisy with with uh uh gay marriage
but the other thing too is don't you
find it weird how quickly the trans
issue just showed up unbelievable it is
it's still I'm still trying to figure
out okay how is this done how is it on
Joe Biden's desk how does he do it
because clearly he doesn't there's no
science that he can quote so this is a
political kind of a political Title Wave
done for a very small minority of of
Americans expecting everybody else a
compulsory kind of like obedience yeah
exactly and um that's the thing is that
people get mad at me when I talk about
this kind of being a fad but I really
think that it is it's it's kind of the
hip thing for a lot of liberals to be
jumping on this bandwagon and like you
say there's no there's no science
there's no I'm sure pull testing even
that shows that the majority of
Americans are really into this and and
really want this to shove down our
throats because they don't this is as
you suggesting just a minute tiny
percentage of the population that is
even
um kind of um enmeshed in the whole
thinking of it that is good and we're
not even talking about changing that we
like Live and Let Live
we're talking about kids yeah like if if
kids can't make up their minds over a
tattoo you can't I mean or or anything
like they they to go to a movie boy
that's an old reference you know what
though I to go to a PG movie yeah no no
I think that the the healthy libertarian
streak in so many of us it is made
manifest with an issue like this because
we we don't want we it is Live and Let
Live for for this they're the ones
trying to shove it down our yeah yeah
it's the it's like okay if it's Live and
Let Live then the parents get to live
and live and don't use this this privacy
excuse like oh the kids shouldn't tell
you Lawrence how you doing I'm good yeah
that's nice nice oh thank you they're um
yeah they're nice they're velcro because
I'm lazy a very lazy person this is the
sign of laziness when you've given up
tying shoes
no that's rich that's what it is I don't
have to tie my shoes you have somebody
else do that for you uh what do you um
what did you make of his appearance uh
on The Daily Show it's amazing do you
know that I think 10 times as many
people saw that here than on the show it
doesn't surprise me I don't know I just
found the president to be very weird
yeah um you know I I don't really think
he has a political Compass because he's
so old at this point that he's not alert
he reads the script he's the person you
know we used to shun the people that put
notes on their hands yeah now the
president can have a teleprompter right
in front of him
um the the kid think is troubling to me
though I mean we have actual issues with
our kids with drugs and all this other
stuff and they want to make this the
central Focus yeah but you know honestly
I don't think we're in the minority on
this anytime there's an issue I always
say go to the group if there's issue in
Black Mirror go to black people so
go to the gay community and they don't
even support this nonsense but you'll
never hear them say that because they'll
secretly say look they'll shun us
they'll kick us out of the club I mean
it's just we're changing pronouns they
them it's not even grammatically correct
and then the fact that the thing that
you know the LGBT community has been
avoiding for a while is to say that they
prey on kids and now you have a whole
group of people within the community
that are preying on kids so they're very
disgusted by this but you you won't hear
them say it because they don't want to
be shunned you can't trust anybody who
doesn't know the the science of grammar
with the actual physical science right
you're screwing up the language stay
away from my kids a happy trans Tuesday
Cat every Tuesday the monologue is about
trans stuff yes it is I don't know if
you guys have noticed that but I sure
have yeah you have you have you pointed
it out to me do you think I go like I
have a cycle what do you do on Monday
night
that's that's a great question because
you what I don't remember
I had friends in town let's just leave
it at that okay yes all right I'll let
you live your life took the day out Live
and Let Live that is you know I coined
that motto Live and Let Live yep
yep so you want to close out the segment
with something thoughtful sure I I would
I think that Mr Mackey over here
which I feel like I need to call you
right now uh you had a you know great
point of all the things he's been
hypocritical on but a lot of people know
this stuff and nobody points it out and
I think Joe Biden we talk a lot about
unflappable strength in a leader right
Joe Biden is maybe the first president
to have unflappable weakness because he
says this stuff that everybody knows is
not true like him in high school and
then him actually support like voicing
support for gay marriage is several
decades longer than I have been alive
right so that's obviously not the moment
that he got there but nobody asks him
anytime usually when this stuff comes up
what no matter what the issue is because
they're just thinking well you know I
got a full sentence out of him and like
therefore it went far better than I
expected I should consider myself lucky
and call it a day so he nobody presses
him on stuff because they just there's
this assumption that he can't handle it
right so it's unflappable weakness
should be the the title of his Memoir
you could just keep writing the same one
year after year because you won't
remember that's a terrible thing to say
but I'm not going to retract it
I feel like I'm with your like your more
successful uncle or no you're older more
successful successful brother Biff I was
just I was just thinking unflappable
weakness is what I would call my muffin
top
just the idea that you use the phrase
Muffin Top is making me vomit
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else